So a few months ago, I was at a wrap party.
Like when you finish filming a project and everyone gets together to celebrate
the fact that it's over and it's done and we're all unemployed again.
To another existential crisis that we will never be hired again and we'll be realized as the frauds that we secretly believe we are.
*Clink*
Anyway, I was at this party
and you know how parties go.  You get into different conversations with people
some you know, some are strangers.
Hi.  I'm Mikey.
Oh hi, Anna.  Nice to meet you.
Cool.  Haha.
Five minutes into the conversation, he said
Oh cool, my girlfriend and I have a puppy.
Shut up!
And I felt this immediate and huge sense of relief.
And I realized that the entire time we were talking I had been doing this balancing act of trying to be friendly
but not too friendly so I wasn't leading him on
but also not trying to be a bitch.
And when he finally told me that he had a girlfriend I was like ah, I can just be myself now.
What?  Shut up.  Show me.
I've got a video.
Awwwwww!
And I started thinking, you know, some guys probably don't even realize that we have to go through this.
Like a couple of weeks ago, this guy approached me in a parking lot.
Hey!  Hey!  Excuse me!
Yes?
Hey, I was wondering if you wanted to go get coffee.
Oh, I'm in a relationship but thank you.
Yeah.  No problem.
That's probably how he remembers it.
If he remembers it at all.
But do you want to know how I remember it?
Hey!
Y-yes?
Stay calm.  Inhale lots of air in case you have to scream.
Go for the eyes and balls.  Don't forget to bite--the jaw is the strongest muscle you've got.
Shit--where's my phone?  Maybe I can have my fingers on 911.
Let's get coffee.
Oh.  Oh my God.  Thank God.
Why did he run at me in an empty parking lot at night?
Jesus, that was scary.
Uh, I'm in a relationship but thank you.
Oh my God, why isn't he saying anything?
Why is he just staring at me?  Oh my God.
Why are you just staring at me?  Oh my God!
Fine.  No problem.
Yup.  You know, there's a study done awhile ago
that sums it up perfectly.
Men are most afraid that women will laugh at them.
Women are most afraid that men will kill them.
So the next time you think that women are a little bit complicated, remember we see the world through very different perspectives.
And who knows?  Maybe that guy actually thought
Hi!  Uhm.  Be brave Mike.
You can do this.  You can do this.
I was wondering--you can completely say no, it will be totally fine--
Uhm.  She's just a girl.  She's not that scary at all.
Do you want to go get coffee sometime?
No!!!!!!!!!
I'm Anna Akana.  Stay awesome Gotham.
This is Beetle.
Oh my God, he's purring.
Oh my God.  I want to say thank you so much to my BFF Audible for sponsoring today's video!
Oh my God you guys!  Thank you!
Audible has an unmatched selection of audiobooks, original audio shows, news, comedy, and so much more you guys!
Right now, I'm listening to "The Name of The Wind."
Because Game of Thrones left like a gaping hole right here in my heart and I need to fill it with some more Fantasy.
And my favorite, because I live in L.A., is I get to listen to Audible whenever I get stuck in traffic or whenever I'm doing laundry
or whenever my eyes are full but I really want to fill my ears.
You can go to Audible.com/anna, because they're offering a free 30 day trial for you to try out their service!
And you can download "The Name of The Wind" or just browse their unmatched selection and download whatever your choice.
Don't forget.  That's Audible.com/Anna.  Oh my God thank you, you guys!  Oh My God!